effectivement si on prend mesure après
mesure on peut se dire qu'il y a des
choses qu'il a qui l'a fait qu'il
emprunte au fond au projet de la droite
tout ou partie il supprime pas
totalement lisf il en fait que la moitié
mais ça va quand même dans cette
direction-là la réforme de la sncf
les ordonnances loi travail etc mais
est-ce que ça suffit à définir ce qu'est
un homme ou une femme de droite de mon
point de vue non pourquoi
parce que je pense que la politique ça
se définit par rapport à un tout vous
êtes de droite quand pas uniquement sur
une seule mesure
vous êtes de droite pour moi quand vous
baisser la dépense publique
quand vous baisser les impôts quand vous
avez une politique régaliennes forte
c'est à dire est-ce que emmanuel macron
s'est attaqué au problème de
l'immigration aujourd'hui la réponse est
non est-ce que ce moment-là loisy
l'immigration elle élargit le
regroupement familial offrait réhausseur
elle elle a modifié des technicalités
mais sur le fond jozi le délai dernière
mais ils ont toujours gagné à plusieurs
sur le fond ça les gars ont hurlé les
associations locales mois qu'elle n'est
pas tant de gauche que ça cette loi
zioui enfin je veux dire ça c'est c'est
parce que sous prétexte que la gauche de
la gauche hurle du coup on dit que c'est
un projet de droite mais la droite
qu'elle ne relève pas forcément la
bouche de la zone et je vous me
permettez aucun député de droite n'a
voté cette loi il y a eu un nombre
incroyable d'amendements qui ont été
déposées et le sectarisme
malheureusement de la république en
marche a fait qu'aucun de ces
amendements n'ont été prises en
considération et pour nous c'est une loi
qui va pas dans le bon sens parce
qu'elle élargit le regroupement familial
aux frères et vos soeurs et que
malheureusement elle ne traite pas le
problème de l'immigration 262000 titres
de séjour délivrés l'année d'air
un record depuis 43 ans c'est bien cela
politique d' emmanuel macron quand on
parle de l'asile on sait que ces cent
mille demandes par an et il n'y a même
pas 7 à 15% qui vont être reconduits à
la frontière donc c'est là encore une
façon de laisser sur notre territoire
une immigration illégale
continuez donc de droite sur le rival ya
bien sûr que non sur le terrorisme sur
le communautarisme des positions qui
sont très ambigu ce n'est pas clair
vous voyez bien qu'ils emmanuel macron
s'adresse souvent aux différentes
communautés et de ce point de vue là il
n'a pas pris selon moi à bras le corps
un sujet majeur et c'est pour ça qu'ils
emmanuel macron de mon point de vue
n'est pas de droite
et quant au reste tant que vous ne
baissez pas la dépense publique
je suis désolé ça m'agace d'ailleurs
quand dans mon camp on parle d'un macron
libéral ou ultra libérale quand vous
avez 55 % du pib en dépend afin que la
dépense publique représente 55% du pib
nous ne sommes pas un pays libéral nous
sommes un père et un pays biberonné à la
dépense publique et à l'impôt